tout de suite d'en parler direct info ou
intox
info ou intox avec anthony st léger
anthony bonsoir à tous vous allez
répondre à plusieurs internautes ce soir
qui nous ont alertés sur une vidéo mise
en ligne avec mise en lien avec les
tensions actuelles entre le rwanda et la
république démocratique du congo va
effectivement mises en ligne aussi hein
ça marche mais effectivement mises en
ligne l'occasion pour moi de vous
rappeler que vous avez à plusieurs
moyens à votre disposition pour si vous
souhaitez que l'on vérifie pour vous
l'authenticité de photos et de vidéos il
ya bien sûr la page des observateurs de
france 24 la page facebook ce numéro
whatsapp aussi vous pouvez nous envoyer
votre message ou encore le compte
twitter info ou intox et 7 ans l'eau
quand celui ci qui a choisi a par
exemple cet internaute pour nous
interpol et pelé pardon elle cherche à
démêler le vrai du faux dans la vidéo
que voici regardez une vidéo d'une
trentaine de secondes on voit des hommes
qui fuient des coups portés ici et là
parfois avec des machettes et ces images
elles cumulent à chaque fois plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de vue on a ce type
de commentaire ici c'est le tweet qui
justement à alerter l'internaute qui a
fait appel à nous un tweet qui
interpelle vous le voyez la communauté
internationale mais également human
rights watch ou la communauté est
africaine et qu'est-ce qu'il nous dise
ce tweet et bien qu'il nous dit ceci
quand nous demandons à la communauté
internationale d'intervenir il pense que
nous plaisantons l'idéologie des fdlr
alors les forces démocratiques de
libération du rwanda on rappelle
brièvement ce mouvement armé en rd congo
formé par les hutus après le génocide
des tutsis en 94 idéologie dont qui
serait insuffler aux congolais
particulièrement aux fardc les forces
armées de la république démocratique du
congo très vite le parallèle avec les
prémices d'un génocide en référence
évidemment celui de 94 effet on a par
exemple ce commentaire qui nous dit
qu'un génocide tutsi a lieu actuellement
à en rdc pardon et sept autres qui nous
dit un peu la même idée que je ne
retrouve pas voilà ici pardon et sept
autres gènes sid est en cours l'idée
donc avec cette vidéo d'une attaque en
rd congo menées par des pros tout à
l'égard des tutsis c'est l'idée mais
cette vidéo elle ne montre pas des
tutsis pourchassé par des congolais avec
des machettes a effectivement absolument
passer
les commentaires en fait justement qui
vont pouvoir nous aider pourquoi parce
qu'ils vont nous aider à retrouver
l'origine de la vidéo l'un d'eux parle
de kuluna alors qu'est ce que sont les
kuluna c'est le nom donné dans les
années 2000 à ces gangs ultraviolents
deux jeunes hommes des criminels qui
sévissent à kinshasa donc la capitale de
rdc qui s'affrontent régulièrement et ce
malgré les opérations de répression
menées par les gouvernements successifs
un journaliste congolais qui travaille à
la fp et que la rédaction des
observateurs de france 24 a contacté
nous informe en fait que la scène en
question a lieu en janvier
2022 en janvier dernier le 17 janvier il
a publié cette vidéo sur son compte
twitter il nous explique à l'époque
qu'une une riveraine l'avait interpellé
l'avait alerté sur ce qui se passait
près de chez elle et lui avait donc
envoyé cette vidéo alors la rédaction je
précise n'a trouvé aucun écho dans les
médias locaux sur cet événement
événement qui sait être déroulés ici à
lemba c'est un quartier de kinshasa donc
on est évidemment en rd congo ces
violences qui a terrific bien évidemment
la population mais qui n'ont absolument
rien à voir avec le mouvement rebelle du
m23 et l'armée congolaise les violences
entre les deux se sont intensifiées ces
dernières semaines le mouvement rebelle
jean xxiii que le rwanda est accusé de
soutenir par la rd congo ce que dément
kigali qui accuse kinshasa de soutenir
les effets de les fdlr alors je vous
parlais au début de semaine d'un fox qui
accusait les rwandais on a ce soir un
exemple qui vise les congolais une
preuve une fois de plus que dans ce type
de situation de crise ou de guerre les
discours de haine la désinformation elle
se fait bien des deux côtés
n'en déplaise à nos détracteurs merci
beaucoup anthony st léger pour toutes
ces précisions très importante on peut
retrouver votre chronique bien sûr sur
notre site internet
points comme nous on se retrouve dans
quelques instants à 22h30 heure de paris
pour un nouveau journal parlé direct
continue
[Musique]